this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 25. I'm sitting here with Echo
Charles
allegedly sure allegedly uh so I wanted
to talk to something today
to kick this off something I used to
call the classic team guy over
correction so so what this is
guys would make a mistake right
what a platoon would or a platoon leader
or you know a squad leader or a fire
team leader someone would make a mistake
on a run this is this is in the uh
Advanced SEAL training
and I'd give them some kind of
corrective measures right
I would give them some feedback and some
corrective measures that they could take
and nine times out of ten they would do
an over correction
which which I would then call the
classic teen guy over correction because
that would be the next thing I tell them
I'd be hey you just did a classic team
guy over correction
they would over correct it if I told
them they need to be more aggressive
they'd be freaking psycho aggressive
if I told them their plan was too simple
they'd go hyper complex if I told their
plan was too complex I'd make it so
simple it wouldn't get anywhere if I
told them they were too loud moving to
the Target they would be so quiet that
it would take them an extra hour and it
would fail if I told them they were
moving too fast
they would slow to a snail's pace if I
told them they were moving too slow
they'd freaking go Mach 9.
classic team guy over correction slash
overreaction
so there's this this doesn't only apply
to seals this applies to us as just
humans and that what I think applies to
humans is we over correct we overreact
that's what we do
you hear something
or someone says something to you or
something happens and your initial
reaction is gonna be an overreaction
or an over correction of what you're
doing
and what I'm saying is don't don't do
that
I know this is really simple advice
but don't do that
the way that you avoid doing this is by
actually
by actually being aware that it's a
thing right so that's what I would tell
you guys I'd say listen
you're telling like don't over correct
this don't overreact to what I'm telling
you
just make a small adjustment and that is
going to more likely going to be enough
the first report from the battlefield is
always wrong
this is just another additional
statement when you hear something for
the first time it's probably wrong and
I've talked before about the reasons
it's wrong it's wrong because you're
hearing one person's perspective so
something happens out on the battlefield
you give me a report the only angle that
you see is your angle so how can that
angle possibly
see everything or give a complete
picture the answer is it can't what
about the fact that you're super
emotional
that's all wrapped up in the first
report
so
the first report's not right and so when
you hear something for the first time
don't overreact to it don't over correct
it
what else happens the emotional part
that's the driver of your reaction
so it's already out of control
something happens and you react to it
it's an emotional response that's the
initial response it's an emotional one
so it's too much
so guess what we have to do we have to
we have to counter that
we have to counter the overreaction
guess what happens when we counter the
overreaction we overreact in the other
direction
and we end up porpoising which I
explained to Dave Burke the other day
good deal Dave yes we end up we're a
little too deep in the water on our dive
rig so we come up and when we come up we
over correct and now we're too shallow
in the water so that we over correct
going back down we end up purposing
wasting a bunch of time and energy and
it's bad so what I'm saying here is stay
balanced don't don't stay calm stay
balanced stay calm don't overreact it's
really it's a really
it's a really simple concept
and it makes a big difference in the way
your world
Goes Forth
yeah that's uh
caught something you said which
kind of made a lot of sense when you
gotta be aware like be aware of the the
circumstances in which you are reacting
in all likelihood overreacting right
just being aware of being aware
like that's kind of the the biggest step
because it's like simple but not easy
right it's not easy because
the thing creeps out of nowhere
sometimes so you want to create a
trigger in your mind that when something
happens you got to say to yourself don't
overreact okay so yeah so I thought
about that the very next question is
like when do you like you kind of do
this pretty naturally
um I'm assuming you've been doing this
for a long time where you could
essentially detach right like remember
you know how we will talk off air about
how detaching is essentially a
superpower
um so when when did you realize oh yeah
I'll just detach from an emotional
standpoint when you're just talking to
like people
I guess
yeah like when do you when did you
realize that because you can be like
think about like oh yeah I just I just
detach but then it's like what do I
think about detaching all day every day
no that's not realistic so it's like
what like what are the triggers like
what when did you realize like okay I
can do this I realized I needed to
detach when I wrote about in leadership
strategy and tactics on the oil rig all
that stuff
and but then I very quickly realized
that it paid off in every situation
including having conversations with
another human being including anytime I
started getting emotional and because
you think about why would all those guys
staring down their weapons yeah because
they were they were engrossed in what
was in front of them and I realized that
was a bad thing so I just stopped doing
that yeah the temper thing and the the
emotional thing I mean how many times I
guess you know really when I saw the
platoon Commander that we had a mutiny
against and we
he was real emotional and I knew I
recognized how bad that was and then
when Delta Charlie came in not emotional
cool yeah and I realized how cool it was
to be cool okay there you go that is
exactly what I was wondering because so
that contrast in that environment where
you were just paying attention yeah and
then you get that contrast those two
situations back to back it's like oh man
the thing that's hard for me to explain
or hard for me to pinpoint
is why I was paying attention that's the
thing that's a little bit strange maybe
puts me a little bit outside the
ordinary box
not saying good or bad I'm just saying
the fact that I was paying attention to
that is a little strange yeah it seems
like when you kind of put it all
together it does make sense not to say
that this is the explanation but you
know like you said you're
you were always aware that you just
wanted to be a good seal and then you'd
like look at people and be like oh I
don't want to be like that yeah or oh
like that because kind of like you're
looking for the model yeah of good seal
you had like some kind of ambiguous
model in your head I had an idea yeah
yeah and then when you saw actual people
you're like oh that there it is and
you're almost like mentally taking notes
the whole time because you had that
innate like desire to know that and you
know how that works with kind of
everything you know if you want to know
about something or you're interested in
something you're always on the lookout
for it kind of thing so then you get
this guy who you're just taking notes on
how not to be then you get that stark
contrast you're like oh you know yeah so
it's like just seared in your brain you
know a little bit more that makes sense
and the oil rig story I I remember that
and I'm like cool but then
like I guess Translating that into like
an emotional
kind of situation where like you know
just even everyday stuff with your
friends or like with your wife or
whoever and they say something
use the wrong tone with you or some
something come on bro it's not as
obvious I just saw so many loser
situations like that you know what I'm
saying even in like a seal platoon which
is my whole life
at that time right seal platoon is it I
would see somebody lose their temper and
be like oh like oh you're losing your
temper right now frust like imagine this
imagine this here's a really good
example because it's a
it's a really good example if you're in
the water you're on a dive rig and you
get tangled up in your gear
and you lose your temper like you start
freaking out you're you're going to
cause problems now I was in situations
like I'm talking like someone's gonna
die but
you know someone starts getting we'd be
all on the same swimmer line you're
underwater it's dark and someone starts
getting tangled up and starts freaking
out yeah
but they start pulling stuff freaking
idiots bro
and so I remember thinking like what
dude if you are gonna act like that
you're an idiot yeah so the ability to
remain calm
is
and and by remaining calm you're
detached right you can't you're go you
you know they're wanting the same almost
yeah remain calm beat attached but yeah
I remember seeing guys freak out about
you know uh especially underwater
because everybody knows and there is
that element I said No One's Gonna Die
but everybody kind of knows if you're
underwater and you have a situation
unfold
and you freak out
your chances of survival are going down
not up yeah so you have to learn to
maintain your composure in the water and
if you can learn to maintain your
composure in the water
and you know that's going to help your
survivability well then guess what
when I'm on land guess what I should do
maintain my calm
help my survivability
yeah
yeah I mean that kind of did indicates
that you kind of just started to see it
everywhere where
detaching boom that's just like this
very valuable thing
very it's pretty rare I mean in my
experience I don't know about yours but
it's pretty rare that someone can
actively do it that reliably
like you
um so yeah so then you get boom being
aware of it right and then that's when
you can correct
appropriate appropriately yeah
so you ever drank a what do you call
like a THC drink it's like a weed you
know like you got weed brownies no okay
so I was at this meeting right with
actually one I remember Brian Moore
yes okay so I was I was in a meeting
with him bought some website stuff long
time ago and he's like oh yeah I got
prescribed this these these uh sodas
pomegranate flavored sodas but they're
weed infused or whatever I was like I
never had that whatever he's like you
want one I was like yeah whatever I'm
down for the cause so
I drink it and I don't even drink the
whole thing and here's the thing I'm
used to
like beer
out of the but you know an alcohol where
you drink it in like a couple seconds
later you feel it already you know it's
like that kind but it's not like that
where the weed infused soda it like goes
in it tastes like regular soda I'm like
oh whatever I don't feel nothing thing
is weak probably weak you know
bruh 45 minutes later like it just all
hits me at once and I didn't even drink
the whole thing like maybe half maybe
three quarters of it or whatever and it
hits me all at once and I'm like all
like the bad feelings that you get that
people say about weed that's what I was
feeling like paranoid for no reason
um just out of it like couldn't really
pay attention couldn't remember what I
was about to say and all this stuff
I'm but I'm battling through the meeting
right and then Brian goes oh he's like
bro are you feeling that because I'm
kind of feeling mine are you feeling
that I'm thinking oh good that's good he
doesn't realize like how much I'm
feeling it so I'm like I was like oh
yeah I'm feeling or whatever
but by the time it was time for me to
leave I was like I was in no condition
to function as a human being so point is
to my story so I'm driving so I'm
driving home I don't know if I should
have been driving it didn't feel like it
was impairing my ability to drive but my
mental state was like
the opposite of detached like I was so
like in my head right okay so it's a
longer story I'm gonna shorten it so I'm
on the freeway thank you on the freeway
or the highway this is that night around
and not very crowded Wrangler so I'm on
the highway and then
I mean I don't know what Lane I'm in but
I see
like I'm passing people you know so I'm
like oh my gosh I'm going too fast so I
slow down and then I realize like people
are just passing me I'm like oh my gosh
I'm way too slow so I can speed up and I
just kicked the whole way home it was
like that I was just over correcting
yeah
couldn't you weren't detached and
therefore you were over correcting just
yeah the whole time literally so lesson
learned watch out for weed infused sodas
yes and don't overreact
yes that's the lesson I took from it as
well let's get some questions what do we
got all right first question first off
thank you both for what you do
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can
just at Jocko underground.com and we'll
get you taken care of until then we will
see you mobilized
Underground